forty years ago the nation woke up to
the grim news that a mission to free 52
American hostages being held in Iran had
ended in disaster but a senior
investigative correspondent Catherine
Herridge tells us hope resilience and
new military capabilities came out of
this dark chapter late yesterday I
cancelled a carefully planned operation
which was under way in Iran on April
25th 1980 President Jimmy Carter
delivered the sobering news equipment
failure in the rescue helicopters made
it necessary to end the mission two of
our American aircraft collided on the
ground following a refueling operation
but to my deep regret eight of the
crewmen of a two aircraft which collided
were killed outside the US Embassy in
Tehran where the Americans were held
hostage celebrations erupted outside the
embassy there were gunshots going off
former hostage Catherine khob was held
444 days how did you learn about the
rescue in town there were two things
that happen first of all we got a letter
from a student that was not unusual
school children wrote to us a lot she
starts off here Catherine how are you my
name is Jennifer Wilcox I'm sorry the
rescue attempt failed
I hope they try again the second clue a
news magazine inside the embassy
revealed more detailed stories about the
United States and Iran had been torn out
the letters to the editor were still
there and the letters to the editor
talked about people who had died trying
to rescue us these were that the heroes
who paved the way for the modern era
special operations in April 1980 retired
four-star generals Tony Thomas was a
West Point cadet less than a month away
from joining the army Thomas knows
members of the 1980 rescue team but
they're disappointed that they weren't
able to execute
they were very confident that if they
could get there they could rescue our
hostages and then bring them home coab
sees a connection between the rescue
attempt and the selfless work of
Americans in the face of covin 19 it's a
very powerful moment it was
extraordinary lies strangers are gonna
put their lives on the line no that's
what's happening right now if medical
workers whether grocery workers with the
truck drivers with so many many people
the hostages were released on January
20th 1981 Thomas says the lessons
learned from the rescue attempt helped
lay the foundation for the quiet
professionals he led as Special
Operations commander for coab her
deeply-held faith and iowa upbringing
have always sustained her it's a part of
my life I can't deny it I can't pretend
it didn't happen
it was 14 and a half months out of over
80 years I had to let go for CBS this
morning Saturday Catherine Herridge
Washington